i'm learning so much
we both have blue hand towels we have
the same microwave and once i buy
coasters made out of geodes we'll both
have those
yeah
hey desk sergeant said we're hosting a
forensic sciences course yes talked by
dr ronald yee he revolutionized the
field of forensic entomology he is a
rock star oh please rockstars wish they
were he the man can tell how long a
corpse has been decomposing just by
studying the maggots inside i'd like to
see barbra streisand do that not sure
barbra streisand counts as a rock star
sir she sings in english that's rock
music well it sounds interesting can i
sign up
yes
you can but here's the thing if we do
well at this course we receive board
certification which makes us eligible to
receive a grant to open a field lab in
the precinct but
but
whenever we have a speaker come in you
kind of tend to always derail these
things with personal stories that's how
i learn i relate course material to my
experiences subjective learning
millennials
i know it's important so i promise i
won't tell any stories though sometimes
they do come in handy one time all the
boyles were in this fungus cavern and
this massive mushroom comes i am so
sorry i slipped right into it i'll be
good these are all just from this year
this one is labeled august 21st morning
this one is august 21st evening this
entire diary is about an episode of
house hunters this is gonna take forever
i actually took a speed reading course i
tested at 800 wpm that's pathetic i
tested at 802. that's pretty close to
holtscore no no 802 is incredible she
pwned me
i read the entire urban dictionary so i
could converse with the other uniformed
officers finished it in 47 minutes
i've never been so attracted to a gay
man before and i dated several in
college so we have a read-off santiago
we don't have finger guards so we do it
raw okay i normally don't encourage such
childish competitions but this might
help things go faster my only question
is ho are you sure your old-ass eyes are
up to the challenge i know you're just
trying to motivate me but these old ass
eyes will be reading your tombstone
son
time to put my newfound knowledge to the
test
so sir popcorn setting always too short
am i right
i'm sorry on our microwave
we have the same microwave oh i didn't
buy it it um came with that
thomas
thoughts
i have
no thoughts about hummus
if you'll excuse me yeah to solve that
problem we would use fluid dynamic
analysis that is exactly right well done
where's your friend shouldn't he be here
for the plaster removal something came
up so he had to remove the mask which
came off quite easily and run out it was
urgent police business bunch of kids are
being held hostage so he had to go deal
with that oh well if you need to leave
to provide them with backup you know
children can handle themselves
so how's it going what do you want terry
are you just here to fan some more
flames no i'm just here to see who's
losing and therefore has to wear this
hat i made that says more stupider
fine yeah i'm fanning flames fan fan fan
fan fan santiago don't call her santiago
call her virginia slim because i'm
smoking her damn ray you guys are moving
fast but there's no way you're actually
comprehending anything i'm taking my
time and reading deliberately and you
know what they say slow and steady wins
the race
classic reg reader bullcrap yeah what
are you gonna say next that you read to
relax
[Music]
nognog little christmas humor that's the
nog from eggnog used in place of knock i
stand corrected he loved it
captain
i want to tell you something
i think you're
like when i was a little girl you think
i'm like when you were a little girl
forget it the moment's passed is this
about your toast
how'd you get that gina gave it to me
very well written
there are several compelling anecdotes
the fonts suit the tone good work
i did feel however the word choice could
have been improved in spots i mark them
hawk for
awkward
i know you may not see yourself as my
mentor but of course i do i've been
mentoring you all this time
this is day
1282 of a nine-year mentorship i had
mapped out for you under ordinary
circumstances i wouldn't reveal this to
you until day 3 300. it was real
there was a finder not anymore the real
hero here is the binder under cheddar
subsection walk subsection walks with
kevin
we found this special spot this is
ridiculous neither of you have even
taken a bathroom break are you kidding
me do you think world record holder
howard berg would stop in the middle of
a read-off to
going on inside the other it's nothing
it's my guide finger got paper burn let
me see
santiago you're hurt
don't be a hero
damn
you must have been cooking i was let's
take a break put some ointment on that
right and when i come back my finger's
slipping all over the page nice try i'm
not falling for any of your tricks oh
but you already have while you were
waggling your finger in the air i've
been reading all this time out of the
corner of my eye damn it it should take
70 seconds for you to fully gauge
someone's character here's what to look
for grammar posture scent attire level
of perspiration type of shirt color
what's the best type of shirt color
english spread obviously but let's hold
the questions until the end when people
say good morning they mean hello when
people say how are you they mean hello
when people say what's up they mean i am
a person not worth talking to there are
two acceptable sleep positions on back
toes up arms crossed or on back toes up
arms at the side do not trust any child
that chews bubble gum flavored bubble
gum do not trust any adult to choose gum
at all never vacation in banff
so i'm positive the murder happened
inside this apartment but csi could find
no traces of blood i'd like to ask the
fbi to bring in a team of lab techs this
would require commissioner kelly signing
off before i make that ask is there
anything else we can do um i'm pretty
sure there is are you thinking what i'm
thinking i am now
we need ye oh he's not that guy that led
that seminar where you guys turned boyle
into a mummy and then he pushed him down
the stairs whoa rosa easy no one pushed
boyle down the stairs right we may have
plastered his eyes shut and left him to
wander around blindly but he fell down
on his own it was a classic accident
exactly anyway dr yee is a genius in the
field of forensic entomology they call
him
father fly
how cool is that zero percent how are
insects gonna help us there weren't any
in or around the body oh my god
you still think forensic entomology is
all blowflies and screw worms don't you
[Laughter]
oh
it's a good one santiago
you should take the lieutenant's exam
hey dr yee has recently bred a species
of fly that has increased sensitivities
to certain human proteins they can
detect trace amounts of blood even if
it's been cleaned with bleach or masked
with animal urine oh i was building to
that thanks for stealing my thunder this
is nasty terry hates bugs too many eyes
and legs would you still hate bugs if i
told you that there were thousands of
tiny mites that live in your eyebrows
and that keep them from being weighed
down by oils
yes look i really think we should go
with the feds on this no we're bringing
in yi i'll make the call right now oh
can i listen on speaker is there
anything in those diaries that can help
us find him debbie mentions her mom a
bunch and one of the ones i read seems
like she tells her everything oh that's
a good lead it is a good lead isn't it
did you hear that speed freaks let's
find out all we can about the mob i'll
start reading right away because slow
and steady wins her mother's name is
margaret jean folger she lives in benson
she drives a maroon lexus vanity plates
derrick's mom she's married three times
to horace mills then frank yelter and
then james falls she goes grocery
shopping on tuesday water aerobics on
wednesdays no club on friday she drinks
too much wine always a pinot grigio
always from napa the race slow and
steady wins the race
he's here dr yee is on his way up how's
my breath oh perfect he's gonna love it
this is not a good color on you guys
speaking of bad looks sarge what is
going on with your eyebrows man i shaved
them off cause of the bugs
sharon said you couldn't notice you're
in light terry you look like a
straight-up fool damn rosa no diaz is
right your face is horrifying you should
leave before hello dr ye
out back now captain holt nice to see
you again please call me raymond unless
that feels weird you don't have to i'll
answer to anything raymond works
so i understand you have a potential
crime scene and you'd like to find some
blood well i brought along several
hundred of my best detectives to help
out oh my god i'm star-struck we all are
so what made you think of using
drosophila as a method of searching for
blood traces have you ever read sungsu's
textbook the washington way of wrongs
from 1235 no yes which edition it tells
the story of the first known use of
forensic entomology a farmer was slashed
to death a local judge asked everyone in
the town to lay down their sickles and
though they all appeared clean one
attracted horde of flies the insects
could sense the blood even though it was
invisible to the human eye wow what an
interesting story yes i did arrest him
oh oh my
[Laughter]
we made a joke together
okay
you